gee whiz this is a wild story we're
streaming in the quest for renewable
energy some ideas are right here than
others but this one may take the cake
this P power toilet converts urine into
electricity and might just be crazy
enough to work
the hope is that the power will be used
to light toilets and refugee camps where
women are at heightened risk of sexual
assault during the night the toilets use
microbial fuel cell that converts
microbes into fuel
thus lighting the cabin as one release
themselves science is pretty awesome
right likes pretty loose because I think
you're like wow science man it works it
actually works it's tested I've never
really thought of doing something like
this but that if they can make P you
know turn into electricity that's a
pretty badass yeah think about that
never crossed my mind yes yeah so we can
turn P into electricity we did a story a
couple weeks ago about a bus in the UK
being powered by poop wow yeah so I need
to go back and check on that one yeah so
we're just batteries we're just pee poop
batteries I love the Oh matrix I love it
I am a little bit concerned about this
this situation though a trip like
lighting
you know the refugee camps and things
like that the bathrooms because I feel
like is it gonna have a backlash where
it's just kind of like like like
lighting up the area where the women are
going you know I'm saying we're not sure
what you're saying no but I'm I'm saying
like okay so these women it's this is
used to protect the women Yeah right
yeah but I'm these people the men don't
seem to really care in general they kind
of don't care if they're assaulting like
it's not like a hidden thing like this
is happening a lot so what I'm saying is
if it's a lit up area don't you feel
like they'll be like oh look at all the
women we're going to the bathroom late
at night right look at all those gang
women those are little they light up
when they're going p to like or is it oh
no well I like yeah I found the toilet
and I'm paying okay well there's a light
so you're you think it's possible that
the electricity is only working while
the pee is action
they somehow store the PMS yeah Betty
gives you like that and the thing is is
also if the men don't know the women are
going to the bathroom and then they go
to the bathroom and then it lights up is
that just like a giant advertisement
like I'm here not not only not only to
watch them but like to like oh now I can
go find my I wouldn't want that yeah do
you think it's kind of interesting that
they're starting to do this in places
like this I feel like this is the type
of thing if they said to people in San
Francisco or to people in LA like you
can power your house with your pee and
poop I think a lot of people would do it
and why not it saves some money right
and like people love what's good for the
environment would you do it you would do
it and think about it but it's it's it's
limitless really like you could have
bars like fully powered by all the
people that were using their bathrooms
from all the heavy drinking their entire
electric greg could be powered by this
so this is kind of future right this
reminds me of like there's a couple gyms
that like are actually some of the
electricity is actually powered by the
people that are on the treadmills this
is like the future of technology right I
mean I think it's a pretty awesome
invention like why not it's something
that would just be wasted yeah and now
it's being used to create something that
would have used resources yeah you know
why do you guys think we're so fearful
of bodily functions like everyone loves
fart jokes we did the poop bus story and
made a zillion puns like but this is
natural stuff why does that still like
is it just like our four-year-old self
is still acting out oh yeah I think it's
totally that like although I totally
embrace Frederickson bodily function
wholeheartedly oh you brought us home
with a bang what do you guys think P for
electricity poop powered buses is the
future gonna be crappy let us know in
the comments right down below
or